[Music]
welcome back to another phenomenal
episode of the careful boys for today
warning dude give me a round of applause
what's War told you last time Red Bull
the [__] red a Red Bull every off the
Record every three videos every off the
Record he needs a Red Bull no warning oh
my goodness you what you Donald Trump
how he drink like 20 of those a day how
what's the average day average oh how
many I don't drink these I don't drink I
don't drink these anymore I only drink
them one on my JK do you like Donald
Trump or love like or love welcome back
to a super ridiculous episode of the car
boys where today we hope to be sponsored
by Red Bull eventually thank you Steve
Green I would love to be sponsored by I
would love to I get my shin tatted if
the team get sponsored by Red Bull Beck
I think all we got to do is just email
them but we never made the we never
tried I'll do it dude we
dance you guys don't give a [__] all
right here we go can you connect us with
Red Bull you do so many things about Red
Bull check it out we don't do cool stuff
this is pretty cool conversation cross I
could spin around in the CH oh this is
Extreme Talking Dude oh that's true it's
extreme talking they do e Sports this is
like lateral I I know how to pitch I'm
going to be like do you want to be a
part of a group you do Extreme Sports
Extreme this but have you been around a
guys that does extreme speaking we do
all the controversial things he's got a
point there yeah dude it's really
gooders nobody could talk for this long
I think we could we could maybe start
pushing that campaign and see how much
momentum it builds in like six or seven
years hey what if we had one of those
big red bulls where you take the lid off
and it has red bulls with ice in it what
about at the end of the year we build a
float that flies off the cliff in the
Red Bull flying games you oh yeah but
the entire time we're just talking I'll
pilot it bro I'll pilot it no dude we're
just going to talk extremely around just
go like this right yeah we're dead yeah
we're dead talk extremely
so here's the question all right we're
going to get intimate we're going to get
personal we're going to get private what
is something weird that you do and you
wonder if other people do as well oh
interesting I don't think anyone does
what I do you got to tell me y'all are
already beating me I know that I'm
pretty normal you got to tell me what's
weird cuz I think it's normal we should
probably wait for Joe yeah we wa for
there are like normal ones where I hear
like dudes on the internet say like
they've never like like smell their
balls
that's gay you don't smell your balls no
but like if you don't do it that's kind
of stupid how do you what do you mean
you got you got to check you got to
check you got to check but you also kind
of know at this point when you're a
little smelly no cuz for sure but
certain like boxers [__] [__] up you
know and then and it's like all right do
I need three like three showers do I
need two showers you know so you be
chicken ball chicken but I've heard guys
say like no dude that's [__]
weird that's [__] weird I like that
guy I don't like the way he talk no he
sucks dude that's the internet guy guy
yeah yeah that guy [__] sucks hey why
you smelling your balls you're [__]
gay and you wonder if the world does
this too other people yeah that means
you also think it's weird too yeah but I
don't think I anything I do is weird but
the world thinks I'm weird there's
nothing that you do that you think is
weird no nothing but people think I'm
weird and I think you're weird because
you're not comfortable with yourself oh
you're very weird though kind of bar
you're that's weird for even thinking
that with all due respect you're very
strange person yeah you're probably it's
not
strange one
here that might be true they live in
delusion and I don't and I'm the weird
one yeah that's a delusional you live in
Freedom you live in Freedom Joe Joe I
see objective realities them Joe's
pretty free dude yeah he's like he's
figured out the Matrix he's for sure the
most free yeah yeah
definitely that song lonard Skinner
Freebird that was about me yeah I
believe it what yeah like what type of
[__] like smelling your ball like what's
weird yeah what is weird Weir you do so
I Inspire my brain oh I got you I
[__] love killing ants yeah okay I
love it I think I'm kind of weird about
it they say that's sociopath activity I
think it's probably the murders I think
that they just pushed me too hard do you
get creative with it why act if you get
creative with it it's that might be a
little weird no I I I just have a method
now vacuum isolate like like remove they
how they're getting into my home you you
find the trail find the trail isolate
where coming from seal it and then I do
my favorite part burn the rest I vacuum
those [__] vacu oh I do that
too vacuum I'm a big fan of that and I
do feel like I have a little too much
fun when I do that um recently it's been
more mosquitoes in my house and like
I'll SP I'll spend I'll spend way too
long killing mosquitoes in the gym like
so I have I'll be training clients
sometimes this is bad business but it's
fine and I just won't pay attention to
them cuz I'm trying to kill these
[__] mosquitoes but at the end it's a
long game because for them it's like
they don't want to get bit by mosquitoes
yeah know you're helping I got to
[__] take care of this you know why
is vacuuming insects so fun though it's
so fun I don't know did you know that
toilets evaporate when you leave them
too long without flushing no I did not
know that say that again why are you
telling me that I left a home for quite
some time I'm not going to tell you the
duration and when I got home all my
toilets were empty Oh you mean the water
evaporates yeah you said the toilet
evaporates the whole porcelet ball a
little confused toilet water has Joe
been gone for 100,000
years the porcelain evaporated Joe's
just been Joe's not weird though yeah
yeah toilet water the toilet water makes
sense but that's pretty crazy but I
didn't it's so much water what does this
have to do with the prom but but but
listen listen still there's so much
water right and he's wondering if
anybody else takes sh it doesn't care
all I'm asking is is have you have you
waited that
long okay and did you know that when it
evaporates fully the Cockroaches and
bugs come out from underneath and then
when I got home I was like I got to go
pee right so I'm I open the [__]
thing cockroaches pulled out I'm peeing
all over [__] cockroaches and [__]
and I was like oh my God this [__] the
toilet Bowl's empty of water I'm
unloading cockroaches are like oh go to
shower go to shower you know and then
after I
flush vacuum time and then I just
[__] vacu your own pee no the
Cockroach you peed on but you peed on
them and then you flush them and then
you vacumed your piss no around the
toilet bow they already at this time
they ran they're like they're all over
the bathroom tiny ones and they just got
urine on them and they're just going
everywhere and I'm just catching
them we do have a little uh bug gun that
feels a little sadic what's that kind
you know it's a salt gun work pretty
well yeah we have it in the gym because
the Gym's like a warehouse you know so
we'll get whatever is it like a super
soer but with like spray like salt like
a shotgun assault what can you kill with
it uh anything we're we're bopping black
widows yeah we're taking the mothership
down yeah love it that feels pretty good
and that is a little sadistic but I yeah
I don't know where they started that but
I heard when you're a kid if you kill
bugs you have I maybe the route to go
that way early path Nikki told me that
I'm not allowed to walk walk with her
while holding a fly water and I have it
because of mosquitoes dude you have
electric one no I she won't even let me
get it yeah those get the electric
tennis racket one you don't have to
smack anything she says it's too it's
weird it's too weird if so we're walking
around her neighborhood and I'm holding
a I'm holding flash you're protecting
her her interest Sal gun has like Scopes
and lasers you can attach to it you can
build it out yeah you can build it
out cool send me a link my mosquitoes
are hella small you got to [__] aim
small Miss no it's that's kind of fun
yeah cuz you miss a lot but it's kind of
fun but it does spray like a shotgun
does that mean there just salt
everywhere in the gym yeah but it's
like but when you when you have a fly
swatter right and it lands on Nikki do
you smack on the shoulder or something I
would wait for it to move from Nikki but
then how do you just catch it in the air
with a SW you like that oh you wait for
it to land on the wall you [__] hit
that no dude with the electric electric
like the electric one you can hit air
and then it's so satisfying cuz it goes
sometimes they cook bro and and it it it
it it just makes it so much easier to
kill the the insect and you just see
them F just in a second dude they're
doneo between you and Nikki who gets bit
more oh Nikki for sure they love her
brown skin for some reason it's
weird oh I know something weird I do
besides periscoping your [__] besides
that I do that too though
so yeah no I don't that's weird I like
efficiency so I feel like but then this
is also one of those things where I'm
like with Joe where I feel like it's
weird that other people don't do that so
for me if I do things multiple times
then in my brain I'm like okay cool if
I'm already going to do this this is
part of my routine my routine needs to
be as efficient as possible so I don't
waste time so for example if I come back
from working out and it's like lunchtime
I run into the bathroom turn on the hot
water go to my fridge pull out the meal
prep because I know the time that it
takes for the water to get warm I could
put that in the microwave I hit the
microwave to turn to uh heat the meal
prep I go back into the shower take off
half of my clothes and then so in 4
minutes I can shower make my food take
off my clothes and be ready to eat and
in 10 minutes I'm done showering eating
making my food and everything versus no
that's not weird versus I versus like
let's say I feel like if I'm like with
regular people around me they'll you'll
look like you're like a psych they'll do
the same thing but it took them 30
minutes and then they're like wait how
did you just do all that in like 4
minutes I'm like because I do this every
single day so it's my routine
theer do this do four different erands
at one time I do the same I do the same
but some of mine are a little Weir so it
be like shower sink toothbrush take take
a [__] oh okay you know what I mean yeah
yeah it does get a little weirder yeah I
can't mix those yeah it takes a little
weirder but I PE shower take a take yeah
yeah same idea
yeah I'll pee in the shower yeah that's
whatever but not poop I'm not no I'm not
pooping in the shower the shower's just
do you own your home the shower is
evaporating and you pee in your shower
yeah disgusting I pee in my shower too
you don't pee in shower no not since I
became a homeowner only when I was a
renter but but I am pretty polite I
don't like I'm not like peeing on my
wall it's a standup really nice tile one
I'm I'm going straight to the metal
drain that's what I do I'm I'm a
gentleman I pee straight into the drain
so that's not weird me trying to like
ficient I do something similar brush my
straight into the drain dude I'll I'll
floss for like like 30 minutes that's a
little weird that's a little why so long
cuz I just I get obsessive with it are
you sure you do it for 30 minutes dude
I'll I'll watch a whole episode of a TV
show with Tiff and I'm just flossing the
whole time and like I I stand up because
I don't want to floss next to her so I
like stand by the kitchen and I'm like
flossing for like 30 minutes and I think
recently I go that's a little too long
this isn't like something I choose I'll
bleed a little bit too I'll bleed and
I'll Tak me 30 seconds go that's a
little OCD that's a little OCD that's my
OCD is like my so M's kind of tapped
into that I had like um bad anxiety and
it always like goes to my stomach so
sometimes I don't like plan my day
around my poops but it's definitely in
the back of my head you get IBS too yeah
like food a little bit food a little bit
and anxiety so I'm definitely like
planning all right when I got to kind of
eat something so I can kind of poop
somewhere I want to poop I'm a big not
public
pooper I really don't like that that's
where I feel like sometimes this is
going to sound weird but I feel like I'm
not like a dude's dude D just like whip
out their dick and piss anywhere like I
want to piss in a bathroom I'm not like
I'm a want to piss in dud dudes are just
like [__] it on a golf course like yeah
bro Outdoors just swear people do that
[__] all the time yeah yeah yeah I don't
like that and then the pooping same
thing I a little nervous they do they do
but I don't I'm not trying to like fart
in front of him I don't like that so
like I like going to like the you know a
little one staller you know have your
like this room cuz we don't do that [__]
I hate that around he's always ripping
ass and laughing at it I'm like the [__]
yeah you guys do breathing exercises
before going into urinal so you can hold
your breath yeah I do that if it's
stanking yeah yeah yeah yeah I always
assume it's going to be stanking so I do
like two or three deep breaths in order
to be able to hold it for like over 30
seconds and then I walk in and take my
piss it's a fun game but the funny thing
is when you're like little [__] up or
whatever depending on the event or
whever you're at you end up
just anyway you're taking deep breath
and you're like was that worth it but
it's the challenge that you like yeah
can I pee wash my hands and leave on one
breath that's what I try to do cuz it's
better to just not have to take in a big
wolf but you go yeah just a little bit
just to get out dude just a little O2 I
also I this for doing that I mentioned
this before and it's only when I
mentioned this here and you guys were
like really that I was like oh maybe
this is weird but I hate falling asleep
in traffic and one of the most
successful things oh as a passenger as a
driver you know when you're falling
asleep cuz it's just like a late night
or something how do you fall asleep
driving fall asleep d i do driver I'm
like that too yeah I got to I can't I
got to slap my face Yer when I get tired
I get tired so the way but why don't you
pull over and just go to sleep rather
than falling asleep and still trying to
drive so here's the weird part you [__]
guy all right in order to stay awake
I'll turn [__] some like porn on on
my phone I tried that because you told
me it didn't work you're weird that's
what I'm saying I pulled over and jacked
off okay the audio alone I'm already
like wa you listen adult film
soundtracks yeah because late night
drives cuz I'm driving no I I understand
so but it'll wake me up I'll just go
I've done that too and I'm not I'm
somewhere in between I'm not going to
straight fall sleep but it just roll the
window down and turn on some really loud
music that usually I'll be I'll say this
need go to sleep I need go sleep it
doesn't work for me the only thing that
works is I feel like you could chug
through not if it so it depends there's
there's a there's regular Bart right and
then there's like [__] emergency Bart
if it's emergency Bart I can get myself
into like Adrenaline Rush situation but
then yeah get whatever done but then I
won't be able to sleep for like the next
12 hours yeah emergency is a completely
different adrenal when adrenaline's
there if you're not in adrenal it's not
necessary to get so crazy so so porn
didn't work on you to keep you awake I
tried I put on I was like I still like
so IM imagine imagine a cop walks up to
Bart's truck wrapped around a tree and
he sees Bart pass out of sleep with porn
on bad I just need to pull over and just
take a quick like little 10-minute nap
and then I feel I tried his technique
and I pulled over jacked off and then I
went back to driving now you feel awake
you more sleepy I feel sleepy I got even
more sleepy you got eat some sour
candies that helps I won't always have
gummy bears on you got to be ready dude
you got to be ready always got to have
okay I'm just saying it's a weird thing
that I do I'm wondering if other porn
doesn't W me up in the [__] wake me
up that's weird it wakes me up here's
another thing I I always do when I'm
eating I always take off my shoes that's
a little weird really yeah like
yesterday at the tii restaurant always
take off my shoes know you take off your
I don't know why and I always cross my
legs and it doesn't matter how nice the
restaurant is I'm taking off my shoes
and that's how I feel comfy you just
feel com you a steakhouse you're taking
off your shoes [__] yeah he's a customer
he's paying for cool oh I know something
that's considered pretty weird I gargled
with I gargle with ocean water when I go
swimming it's a little odd yeah you
clear the throat dude just swimming and
then sometimes water gets in my mouth
and I
go and I'm I just don't spit it out I
mean I gar you're swimming and it get
okay well yeah well sometimes I'm just
swimming and I'm like oh the natural
Waters of
Hawaii like being little odd my neighbor
thinks I'm weird cuz I Pace while I'm
while I'm watching sports what do you
mean I feel like that makes sense cuz
you you're [__] hear that I do
anything phone calls like real serious
phone calls I Pace like I past dur and
everything yeah I can't [__] sit down
fights that I'm really looking forward
to I can't watch sitting down no way I
got to be standing up no way one with
food it's not that weird cuz I think
everyone does it when they're young but
just still do it is like if I have a big
plate of a bunch of stuff like
Thanksgiving or something and maybe this
is like my Eating Disorders but like I
always eat the stuff that's not very
good first oh yeah I do that I do that
too you know I feel like that's like a
8-year-old thing but I still do like all
right I Best For Last yeah I got to like
slam this broccoli then I'll get this
steak in then we're going mashed
potatoes and mac and cheese yeah yeah
I'll do [__] like that the [__] though
that's my favorite one dude stuffing
mashed potatoes all day yeah oh I got
another one this is I hate it when my
body tells me what to do so for example
so when you turn on the porn you're just
like to sleep no yeah like so if I'm
like let's say I'm like sitting here and
then like let's say um it's been 30
minutes and I need a pee and I just peed
30 minutes ago I'm like oh you think you
really need a pee [__] you're
not peeing for another hour you hold it
yeah or if I'm like uh if I'm like just
like just in water or something and I'm
like oh I need to breathe I'm like oh
you [__] little [__] you need a
[__] little breathe breathe again
then I'm like you got to you're going to
hold your breath for another like 30
seconds but that just called discipline
and gangster but I don't think people
like put themselves through that
withhold themselves from peeing yeah or
like [__] I'm like oh you going to
give me a [__] [__] and I'm like
purposely just sit I'll do that till my
tummy hurts a little
bit push so you have an internal bully
is what you have I think so maybe okay I
like to wait a little bit you let it
stoop yeah for poops I like to kind of
push it a little bit is like how long
can I wait the poop oh yeah even if I'm
cold I'm like oh going I need a jacket
oh [__] complain about how cold it is
then take off my shirt and go outside
even more I just stand there like yeah a
little weird oh if I wake up in the
middle of the night you know you ever
wake up in the middle of night you can't
fall back asleep yes dude I [__]
throw on a K's
video
gone gone I'm snoring before it before
at the minute that's not
[Music]
real